cette équipe du chemin réalise une
opération qui nécessite à la fois des
doigts de fée et une patience d'ange
recoudre des vaisseaux si petit
ils ont tout juste le diamètre d'une
aiguille qu'il faut utiliser une
lentille les grossistes en fois pour y
parvenir on appelle ça de la super micro
chirurgie c'est un peu de la plomberie
mais c'est de la plomberie assez
compliqué à faire parce que on est dans
des tuyaux qui font moins d'un
millimètre de diamètre et qu'il faut
connecter deux tuyaux qui ont sont de
nature différente des chirurgiens
opèrent un lymphoedème normalement le
système lymphatique fait circuler un
fluide à dans tout le corps humain mais
lorsque des vaisseaux ou des ganglions
sont endommagés ce liquide s'écoule et
provoque une enflure importante et
chronique sur une partie du corps humain
il y a trois ans olivier a développé un
lymphoedème lors d'une chute en moto
sa jambe a enflé de 50% restera le
moment le plus peiné passerait de la
douleur balles font pas valoir tout à
j'avais beaucoup de difficulté à plier
ma jambe donc à tracy ya une dizaine de
jours olivier a subi la même
intervention que celles ci on a d'abord
isoler les vaisseaux lymphatiques
endommagés puis on les a reconnectés a
de toutes petites veines permettant la
lymphe de s'écouler normalement six
heures sur la table d'opération suivie
d'une période de réadaptation mais dans
80% des cas les résultats sont positifs
patrick dulong encore un vêtement de
compression mais dans le fond la
compression pourrait vraiment moindre
donc ça rend la chose plus agréable et
plus facile arrive un quotidien plus de
vingt mille canadiens pourraient
bénéficier de cette intervention
mais pour l'instant les objectifs du
chum sont modestes aux péris une
douzaine de patients en 2018
et pourquoi pas trouver de nouvelles
applications à cette technologie
la micro chirurgie vasculaire au chum
c'est une longue histoire
c'est une longue histoire la
réimplantation des doigts les
reconstructions de sein les
reconstructions de visages complexe mais
descendre dans ce niveau de diamètre de
vaisseau là c'est nouveau et oui ça
pourrait nous offrir d'autres horizons
dans la microchirurgie plus classique
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal